everyone's been calling me the most
powerful man in Japan the demon Chi
or joke
where am I
and from a look of it this is ancient
Japan
our master has ordered us to kill him on
sight the Joker that's right
Huli do with us last aboot they're all
trying to take over this country and
rewrite history
[Music]
this is it the Batmobile the bad wind
the bat-cycle they've all been destroyed
at the hands of the Joker and I have my
mind my spirit and all of you
[Music]
[Applause]
when the country is in chaos a falling
means are bearing a mask of a path will
come and restore order to a land great
scenery from across the steel pipe Lord
Batman
now what
[Music]
hey everybody you're probably asking
what the hell's going on maybe you've
heard about Batman ninja or a ninja
Batman you can think about it any way
you want to basically it's Warner
Brothers Japan making an anime movie
with the Batman characters but you can
kind of see because they finally did an
English dub of the trailer they released
a trailer for it a while ago but they
didn't have a dub of it so unless you
spoke Japanese it was a little hard to
figure out what the story was actually
about and in what they were doing to
explain how Batman wound up in feudal
Japan important stuff first digital
release is April 24th it comes out on
blu-ray May 8th but the story is Joker
putting a team together and using
Gorilla Grodd to build a time machine to
go back and change history is just they
go back to feudal Japan so when Batman
gets sucked back in time like you can
actually see him in present-day Gotham
City with this big time vortex how did I
wind up here the other side of that is
the Joker's Alliance destroys the
Batcave so he doesn't have any of his
technology available to him which is why
you see him using all the tools that
someone from feudal Japan would have
access to so it's ninja Batman versus
ninja Joker but it's all of the
present-day versions of the characters
that have been transported back into the
past the artwork is from the person that
did afro samurai the director was the
person that did JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
so if you're big anime fan and you liked
the Batman universe of characters this
is probably gonna be fun for you look
they just to Gotham by Gaslight which is
an else world story about Jack the
Ripper done with the Batman characters
they're doing Batman Joker Harley Quinn
Nightwing Red Robin Red Hood and also
they're crediting someone is Robin so
I'm assuming it's the Damian Wayne Robin
you have Dick Grayson Jason Todd Tim
Drake so obviously this has to be Damian
Wayne you have Alfred penguin poison ivy
Deathstroke Grodd Selina Kyle Catwoman
in sumo Bane I love that they made Bane
a sumo so you can tell from a lot of the
character designs that they retain some
of their core attributes just with the
meson sin of feudal Japan
so like Deathstroke has a gun that looks
like it's from ancient Japan the reason
for doing it as an amazed because Warner
brother
Japan wanted to do a project and
obviously animated Japan credibly
popular art form over there but you
don't find a whole lot of mainstream
comic book characters done as anime
they've done it with the Avengers
characters before there been some
limited titles but so for the most part
when you're reading comic books in Japan
you're reading the same issues that
everybody else reads just translated
into Japanese so the director said he
wanted to do an anime inspired Eastern
type story but using the Batman
characters so I think that's why they
invoked the sci-fi time-travel trope to
bring the present-day versions of the
characters that we know back in time
instead of just saying what if all these
characters existed during this time
period instead of during present day so
you have to treat it like what if Heath
Ledger's Joker used a time machine to
try and go back to feudal Japan to
change history and Christian Bale had to
go back to try and stop him I haven't
done a video for Gotham by Gaslight but
for the most part DC's animated movies
are actually pretty solid they have a
pretty solid animation team the people
at Warner Brothers animation are the
people that are also doing Young Justice
season 3 I know there haven't been a
whole lot of updates about that recently
but I did do a video talking about Titan
season 1 because they're all airing on
that same streaming service and I think
that's what'll happen with these big
movie releases too when they do the
animated movies they'll probably drop
them on the streaming service but the
long and short of it is is that Titans
is probably going to premiere sometime
around comic-con like late summer
they'll air all those episodes once per
week and then after that gets done
airing 13 episodes then they're gonna
start premiering Young Justice season 3
so with the latest I'm expecting Young
Justice to premiere late November early
December and that will be 26 episodes
the contrasting the term season 1 season
2 was how are the kids relating to these
adults now how are the freshmen relating
to these seniors and how are those
seniors who were kids just a little
while ago dealing with mentoring these
younger zeros and again all that will
continuing into season three but things
are even more sort of scattered things
kind of fall apart a bit the idea right
now told to me by somebody that actually
works at DC is that they want to keep
new content on they're continually so
like total air Titans once per week then
they'll release Young Justice they have
a new Harley Quinn animated TV series
this is the only concept art that they
have for it fill air all the episodes of
that then they'll premiere another
series then by the end of that they'll
probably be ready for Titan season two
in Young Justice season four and so on
and so forth so if you do live outside
the United States and you're like where
is all this going to premiere for me as
far as Young Justice and that DC
streaming service I think as has been
the case with Warner Brothers with
Riverdale and the new Sabrina TV show
that they're doing they're probably
gonna drop that on Netflix
internationally so like you could watch
Riverdale episodes once per week so no
worries don't worry about it they'll
make more announcements about comic-con
WonderCon is actually happening in March
we might get some more information then
but just be sure to subscribe to get
everything
of course be doing videos for all that
animated stuff when it drops but because
I was originally gonna do a flash season
four video what I'll probably do is if I
can't get that out by tonight I'll do
that tomorrow morning I also have some
new Avengers infinity war so lots of big
stuff coming while you wait for
everything click here for a brand new
spider-man infinity war and you can
click here for brand new flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight